in this video we're gonna talk about
regular expressions also known as red X
red X but has a really different format
than everything else in JavaScript so it
has kind of a steep learning curve and
can be a little bit intimidating
personally a very intimidated by writing
X though I know it can be a very useful
tool and I've used it a lot successfully
what you can do with red X is match
replace search and split strings which
can be one of the most difficult forms
of data to manipulate in JavaScript the
time this would be useful if you have a
website and you want users to create a
password and you want their password to
have at least one number in at least one
capital letter you can use red X to make
sure that their entry matches those
qualifications for it to be valid
there's like I said a lot of ways to use
recs but the most common is when you're
validating user inputted information I
want you to remember this because when
you get to the red X challenges don't
worry it's gonna be okay I know it looks
really different and also if you're ever
trying to do something like validate
user information on your website or your
web page or your bonfire or whatever
think about rig X because it might be a
really efficient way to do what you're
trying to do